please cover overcoming the frustrations
of beginning jiu-jitsu and this is
coming from a 54 year old by the way but
not quitting good good for him that's
awesome
glad you're picking up the jujitsu at 54
years old okay so how do you the
frustrations at beginning JJ and it is
absolutely if you have the wrong mindset
it's viciously frustrating because of
everything we just talked about and you
think oh I'll just do this and let's go
little bit harder and I just won't put
my on there and I'll be able to win
you're not gonna win you are gonna lose
you're gonna lose over and over and over
again to people that are smaller than
you weaker than you not as tough as you
are literally not as tough as you are
you know not as tough as you are you
know jiu-jitsu has a faction of of nerds
for lack of a better word straighten
nerds and no offense to the nerds out
there but you know people that are not
physically active and then some for some
reason they fall into Jersey at some
point and and the and the whole sudden
it got a guy that's and they're not
tough but they'll know the moves and
I'll finish you so that so those the
people you're gonna lose to so and it's
a it's a long long slow journey that
takes a long time now that being said if
you train for a month and someone's
train zero that journeys not that long
you but that guy yeah you you will beat
that guy I mean you know again you take
two people one of them knows jujitsu for
a month and one of them doesn't that
guy's gonna win I mean you know basic
way same way basic same you know he
can't have somebody that's completely
weak but in six months
you're beating anybody that sound for
the ninety five percent that maybe you
99% of people I don't train but but but
as far as like you think you show up and
in six months you're gonna be beating a
blue belt it's not happening yeah yeah
it's not happening a beating a purple
belt is not happening you you're not
gonna you're not gonna catch a purple
belt you know in in your first two or
three years unless you got just somebody
that does lets you yeah yeah of course
you're given like
Jeff Glor he'll let people put him in
all cut he does that in companies you
saw that Metamora see he lets all kinds
of great things happen so yeah
can that happen of course but as far as
legitimately yeah taking someone down
yeah it's not gonna happen to me so so
that's all that's what I'm saying is a
long slow journey especially to because
everyone's on that bus we've talked
about this before everyone's on the bus
getting better so that blue belt that
started that you started six months
behind or a year behind so he's a blue
belt you're a year behind him he's not
stopping getting better so as you start
to pursue his game his game is evolving
and changing and improving so you're not
going to get there and then on top of
that when you do learn something new it
takes time to incorporate it into your
game so if I taught you echo and new
move tonight
I said hey here's the school it's here's
this new setup for the armlock and we
drilled it ten times and you went now
and started to apply that it would make
your game worse because you'd be trying
to apply a move that you don't know 100%
yet like you've got some good solid
moves that you do and those are you know
those work really well so when you start
incorporating this new move you don't
know it well you don't get it all
together so you're gonna fail out at a
hundred times
it's not gonna work a hundred times
before you get it and by the way every
time you tried it on me I got on top and
then I smashed you in the night so
you're you're sacrificing and it's in
every time so you're actually going
backwards a little bit before you can go
forward so that's problematic and that's
very very frustrating occasionally you
might learn something that like really
improves your game dramatically almost
instantly that happens from time to time
someone will say hey put your own
position here or hey you know whatever
the case may be but generally when you
incorporate something new it can take
some time you're gonna get injuries
you're gonna get little injuries you're
gonna get big injuries you're gonna be
sore you're gonna so yes you will be
frustrated so how do you counter all
that you just got to embrace it you've
got to embrace all those things you
gotta enjoy all those things and I hate
to be cliche here but you got to enjoy
the journey you got to enjoy getting
tapped out by somebody that small yeah
be amazed by that you know say dang how
did that just happen that is impressive
you know
you know say hey got a little war scar
on my face I got you know split the eye
open okay cool chicks dig scars you know
I mean just gonna go don't don't don't
look at all that stuff as negative look
at it as you know it's like don't rush
to the end don't rush to the end don't
mean a rush to get there take your time
and enjoy the sights that you're gonna
go for also I've said this before select
your training partners carefully
especially like you're 54 years old you
don't want to be rolling with a 20 year
old steroid freak that's going white
belt trying to kill you you want to be
rolling with a cool mellow purple belt
that's wants to do jujitsu yeah in in
train and finally I would just say
remember that jiu-jitsu should be fun it
should be all those other things all
those frustrated all those challenges
all those things all that humiliation
and humor and getting humbled but should
be a good time you should have fun we're
doing jiu-jitsu I know I do yeah yeah
like a video game right you know I'm in
town for a couple of days man and I came
back and I had a little injury that I
figured figured out took me a little
while got my jacked-up finger it took me
a little while to uh get the right get
the right apparatus to splint it
properly and protect it but it's but
tonight I trained and I was so happy I
was so happy
go on you're getting on the mat just
saying yes yeah that that is how we're
all these all the junk parts that come
with it were quote-unquote jumper you
know like the is yeah I got choked out
aware that's all part of the game seems
obvious right yeah it's all part of the
game but be happy that that's the game
you're in you know so I mean jiu-jitsu
basic I mean if you don't do jiu-jitsu
this would be kind of kind of an insight
basically all it is you go if you go to
a class you go in you you may or may not
warm up you learn a move whether it be a
submission move or just a move you learn
a move two moves three moves sometimes
four moves and then you cut to rolling
straight up you guys are fighting no
strikes that's it you're fighting no
strikes
if you whatever moves you know go ahead
and do them want one in real life
against this guy that's it if you don't
know if that's your first day and you
learn one two three moves
first day you better try to do those
moves that's it so of course you know
two three moves that you learned once by
the way and you roll with someone who
even if he's still a white belt or
whatever he knows those moves and then
you know three four more and he's
practiced some in you know in real time
or whatever I'm crazy is gonna get you
you know that's just how it works
but keep in mind the more you go the
more you do the moves more moves you
learn the more you practice some in real
life the better you get at them and you
know let's go ahead and just apply this
to life as well cuz jiu-jitsu such a
great metaphor for life whatever you're
doing whatever goal you're trying to
achieve if you're letting those
frustrations when you hit those
obstacles if you're letting them control
you and get you down that's the wrong
attitude to have you know look at it as
a learning opportunity look at it as
something that's good that's happening
look at it as a chance for you to try
something new
look at it as the journey that you're
trying to let you in by the way anything
that's easy to achieve and you don't hit
any obstacles well that's not worth it
right that's not it's not gonna get the
full satisfaction that you want out of
that so in life as in jiu-jitsu don't
get frustrated embrace those challenges
because those are what is making this
goal worthwhile I'm telling you when you
let's see you well back to the avoiding
frustration specifically it does how
you're saying training partners that
doesn't make a big difference because
sometimes everyone small like I've heard
of people where their schedule doesn't
allow them to catch like the beginner
class for example so they're like hey
I've no choice I got to do this more
intermediate or advanced class so
they're the only white belt and the next
you know guy even close to the team is
like a advanced blue belt so that's
gonna be a steep learning curve it's
gonna be tough cuz it's how are you
gonna practice your moves in the while
ever you won't get to work your offense
yes really but here's kind of a good
thing you get to work your defense so
when you get the opportunity to exercise
like your offense whether you you get in
another class or he just comes but just
takes longer whatever but you know how
good your defense is gonna be yeah and I
actually so from training with Dean for
so many years you know he's just got
some positions that are brutal brutal
positions and you know for instance his
mount is is outstanding he's when he
gets the mount
when anybody else that I've ever trained
with in my life has mounted with the
exception I guess of Hicks and Gracie
I felt like oh it's not being this is
not you know this is not horrible
scenario right and not that I'm not that
worried I'm not trying to degrade people
I've trained with but that is a grip
Dean has an incredible mount and on top
of that Dean kind of knows my escapes so
whereas if I roll with a random other
really good you know wolf class black
belt they might not know the particulars
of my escape
Dean actually does know those and he's
good and he's good at it so so you're
right in that the more you train with
people that are better than you your
your defense is gonna be very good cuz
like when you mount me I mean you got a
good solid mount but I'm not I'm like
I'm like okay cool all I'm gonna be out
of this and in a short period of time
with with no real threats in in the Riu
bed I mean I'm sure it's the same way
you've got Dean mounted on you I mean my
mount because I don't have a great mount
my mount is nothing compared to Dean's
nothing yeah yeah fully yeah and that's
absolutely true and at the same time
though so what if you fall in and I
don't wanna say it's like a small see
because it's pretty big chance where if
you enter a beginner class there's gonna
get be a guy who's just as much of a
beginner as you could and that's where
you can really flourish because you're
you can practice moves your new moves
which I mean for lack of better term
your junk moves you know and junk people
I will say this though whoever you roll
with whether they're worse than you the
same as you are better than you you're
gonna get a lot out of it all three of
them yeah so you should roll with all
three of those types people I have a
tendency to wanna usually roll with guys
that are you know like good and and I
should spend more not I do I mean I
definitely I train with everybody that
we got at the altar and everybody but I
always prefer of course I guess I
shouldn't say of course because there
are people that are like white belt
hunters that want to go out there and be
bullies I'm not like that I'd rather get
bullied right I want to get I want to
feel the I want to get after it you know
yeah but you definitely get benefit from
training with people that are better
than you worse than you and the same as
you because you
is one of them you're practicing defense
one of them you're practicing pure
offense and someone that's equal than
you you guys are practicing your setups
and and your approaches and you gotta
learn how to defend and do offense and
defense at the same time so it's all
good bro oh yeah that's basically the
concept here roll yes get after it
consider that scenario you bro with then
you're talking from an ideal standpoint
roll with people better than you same as
you worse than you or you know not as
good as you for a beginner that's not
really the option the worse than you
guys that's not an option for a beginner
yeah really ya know so there's no one to
sole them well as far as overcoming the
frustrations or whatever it is a good
situation where you can get in with guys
just as beginner as you and and hope
that they hang around this after a
certain amount of time those guys who
aren't as new or I could see where it
could become frustrating if you were the
guy he was I wonder let's say a guy
that's you have to work late and you can
only go to the advanced class and all of
a sudden you think jujitsu is just
getting crushed yes like and I can't
learn this really you know so I guess
leading distance to understand but yeah
that's that's a good point so keep in
mind that if you're in that situation
it's okay you're gonna you're gonna when
you eventually get to roll with people
that are more your skill level you will
be you'll be that much better off yeah
yeah for sure and watch the first time
you tap someone out with a move that you
learned celebrate that did you yeah
that's a good that's a good time